hello everyone welcome to pi data global
2021 i'm conrad one of the co-chairs of
conference uh we're happy today to have
umel to come talk to us about
hierarchical bayesian models and pie mc3
uh
thank you you know let's get away yeah
yeah okay so hi everyone so i hope
you're all like doing all right i mean
as well as it can be given the pandemic
and everything but yeah thanks for
coming i mean i understand that it would
be difficult to attend virtual
conferences and thanks to the pi data
team for organizing and they had to work
so much so let's get started
so today i'll be talking about
deconstructing hierarchical bayesian
models using the library by mc
and all the slides in the code
can be uh
it's in this repository that you can
check if you want i can drop a link
later in the chat as well if you don't
find the repository
so a bit about me
so i'm a undergrad student in my junior
year i'm from india and
this summer i worked with mc3 back then
they were by mc3 now we're releasing a
new version ymc 4.0
which uh
so yeah the three is gone
so i worked with them over the summer i
was working on extending time series
models and since then i've been working
with those folks and it has been like
really amazing and
by the end of this talk i hope i can
convince you to maybe at least try bmc
if you haven't already and if you have
then well maybe use more of it these are
my contacts in case you need to reach
out or anything like that
okay
so let's get started with it
so now
i planned for the stock to be you know
very accessible so if you haven't really
uh been introduced to bayesian inference
before i mean i cannot really sum it up
in a slide but it's basically just that
um say in frequent statistics you have
these uh
you know
you know
you you just count up that okay this is
what happened and uh this
this exact number is uh the frequency of
this
particular event happening and they're
basically interpreted as long run
frequencies so the goal is to create
procedures with those long run frequency
guarantees
but uh invasion statistics the
probabilities are interpreted as
subjective degrees of belief
and the goal is to
state and then analyze your own beliefs
so yeah you uh you basically have some
beliefs and you update them and then you
get your posterior distribution and this
is where probabilistic programming
languages are very useful because uh
okay now now you might ask me that what
are probabilistic programming languages
so there's this stock of chris on this
back
in you know pi day involve the pi datas
and he said that okay it's basically
just literally any language where you
know the total the overall outcome that
you are getting is not deterministic and
like that's it
i mean you have distributions you don't
have a deterministic
uh way of doing things so you can do
probabilistic programming in any
language which has a random number
generator
this figure is from the architecture
file of ymc3
and so you would get sort of an idea of
how the api works
like we have samplers and we have all
distributions bracketed into continuous
and discrete and processes and
yeah i mean
right now a new changes earlier the back
end was thiano now it just changed to
srm
which
we're hoping will make it
easier to use by mc3 for you okay
so moving on
today what we're gonna talk about is
hierarchical modeling now that sounds
like a fancy term you can build it
in a very bottom-up approach from linear
regression itself
so uh first i'll just tell you about two
of the important terms that we'll be
using when we talk about hierarchical
modeling and then we'll see
you know what it actually is okay so
yeah i mean they're really just
sort of uh
simple ways of saying okay you have a
probability distribution and now the
parameters of that distribution are
itself
derived from another distribution
so yeah that's that's the hierarchy like
this is at one level and the priors for
this distribution are another level
so now this is just an example of a
two-stage hierarchical model
so uh say you have an observation y and
you have a parameter theta uh that
you know governs the data generating
process for right so now you assume that
uh all the thetas are generated
interchangeably
from a
common population and the distribution
is governed by a hyperparameter phi
so there are like three stages in the
hierarchical model
first from why you have the you have the
probability of y
uh given theta and phi
and then
theta given phi is the distribution
whatever we specify whatever priors we
get
so uh
uh yeah you this is like basically your
priors and posterior and likelihood all
combined
just with a difference like this is base
rule with just one difference that we
have another parameter phi or theta
whichever you want to take for uh for
the original prior that also is we're
getting that from another parameter
that's like the only difference
so now i thought that before getting to
the final model that i'll be presenting
we can like make little dummy models
that are like you know we won't be
thinking too much about what parameters
to get because we don't care about the
results in those moments we just want to
see okay how how does it even work or
how am i gonna do the senpai mc3
so say you have these predictors that uh
you know say we took two thousand
uh twenties data
and
uh now we wanna predict that uh how are
the players gonna play in 2021
and so you take 20 19 scores or you take
20 20 is four and you multiply that with
some coefficient and you also know that
okay maybe their position might have
some effect
so you can do this in a couple of ways
that's where we realize that when our
hierarchy models relevant turns out in a
lot of places they're not useful and
using them is sort of counterproductive
but yeah that's for later so
uh
i mean uh but
i'll just get back to the slide after
this one all right so you can see this
so in complete pooling
that's just a term what it really means
is it's just basically linear regression
so this alpha is the only term we should
be thinking about that okay we're
predicting these things and there's
gaussian noise in x as the previous
year's points but the thing is that for
position
we are assuming that whether the player
is a forward or a goalkeeper we don't
care they're all gonna
you know that is not gonna create any
influence about how the data will change
now okay i mean uh if if
if it was a situation where it really
wouldn't create any difference we could
use a simpler model because we prefer
simpler models
but in this case this isn't really a
good idea
you see next so this is just how do you
like you know just build this in pi mc3
so yeah this would probably give you an
idea of the syntax or how you write code
in pi mc3
and so yeah you just give your data as
an array and you give your points
you say that you know alpha and beta and
sigma just like we had over here are
distributions i mean given your specific
data you should you should think a lot
about your priors
whether the variance is too much or too
less or whatever you're doing and
finding c3 also has this imc i'm still
getting used to the fact that three is
removed
so it is this cool thing where we can
get these graphics diagrams right after
building the model so it's easier to
visualize and understand what's going on
so yeah we see that this data goes in
and this
is what we want to predict so yeah
this is what we did in a completely
fooled model but turns out this isn't a
good idea another option which is on the
absolute extreme is unfold models
where we say that
okay you know
we should have a different
distribution for every single player as
in forwards or a whole different
category and
midfielders are a whole different
category but like there are obviously
quite some similarities as well
so this extreme doesn't really work as
well i mean in a lot of cases where
where you know the groups are not that
rigid
so in those cases this isn't a very
i would say
good thing to do
again the only change that we did in the
syntax that was mentioned previously is
in alpha we simply gave so by mc has
these things called shape and size and
dens and quartz so which are basically
for specifying that okay now i mean most
of the computation goes on in high
dimensional areas so how so you're
basically having all these matrices and
you want to say okay what is
how many rows do i have how many columns
do i have so similarly then or just
another one of those things and we're
saying okay we are calculating a
different alpha
uh for
each of the position values and we gave
position over
okay the quads line is not written here
it's basically you give words as a
dictionary where you encode the
positions as say zero one two and three
each for forward goalkeeper defender
midfielder whatever you're taking
so yeah again we have a nice little
figure over here to see what's going on
i mean i think i'm going a little fast
maybe
but yeah i just have a lot of slides and
i just want to go through them and see
if i can
explain something meaningful
so then comes partial cooling
now andrew gelman in one of his books
describes it as you know it's this
compromise between
unfold models and
uh completely pooled models as in we're
saying that
okay you know position does create a
difference but
yeah i mean there's all still football
players in there i mean yeah we we
should probably be having some
similarities between them so we take one
distribution from which we take multiple
alphas
alpha 0 1 2 3 and we use those
for the
for all the different positions that we
have
again we have
this figure now this figure is really
different from
this one
as in
so yeah we're giving last year's points
and we're giving position data
and uh here is our alpha
now over here what what we're doing
differently is first we have an alpha as
we gave previously without the dims then
we have another parameter alpha position
which is basically uh something that
whose mean and variance mu and sigma
because it's a normal distribution
is from the previous alpha that we gave
so all of them
uh so
uh i mean all of them have some sort of
a similarity
so yeah that's
now
uh we can probably get to you know
building the actual model so here i've
just taken all the slides from my
jupiter notebook itself and i'm just
going to quickly run through them so
i'm someone who thinks that you know the
data you get kind of really matters for
whatever models you're building i mean
i mean i'm not the only person to think
that but yeah
so now there is this repository that
i'll probably add a link to in the in my
notebook as well uh fantasy premier
league which has all this data
and
so we i just took many 20 and 20 21's
data from there
and
okay
much wrong with my okay yeah so now
because we want to use 20 20 and 2021's
data together as in we want to take some
parts of uh so by previous year's points
i meant that okay this particular player
in this game week
what were their points
at that point of time and we use that as
some sort of an estimate of that you
know it has to be something
slightly larger or slightly lesser than
that because of some factors maybe the
fixture maybe the opponent they're
playing against something like that so
yeah we take the same players because
yeah
and then
uh yeah we just add those total points
in the new database as in the original
one that we'll be using
now over here we we
had to you know like all that one hot
encoding stuff and everything this this
is not that this is just
uh saving all the teams as numbers now
another thing that i did was i was like
okay we'll take last year's teams
total goals and schools defended and
teams that won and everything to sort of
cluster all these teams
into you know say four categories that
these are like the best
five teams then the okay five teams and
the five worst teams in this particular
area based on our prior knowledge and
this is something that is always
emphasized in bayesian statistics isn't
that yeah i mean uh your domain
knowledge is something that is very
relevant when you want to say
that what kind of predictions we're
trying to make so we took that
and uh yeah from those we just made
these clusters where the ranks were out
of
from one to four
this idea was originally in a paper
and i have no idea about the name but
yeah it is mentioned in the references
of this presentation itself
so they took a few of these are
clustering
things in
only one parameter i think
they just took the final team wins as a
parameter so i was like okay maybe we
can do something for defense and attack
as well
and we did that
the jupiter notebook slides came out
really weirdly for some reason i
converted them to pdf yeah another
parameter that i took was
the initial value that you know all the
players were given at the beginning of
the game weeks as in okay
this particular player is valued some
million billion dollars etc and that
would again give us some domain
knowledge that we don't have the
capabilities to model
because um like obviously uh that would
that would say a lot about you know
their entire previous history
and so we took that
now that is something that we'll just be
multiplying with the coefficient because
we don't really
know how much is that supposed to expect
and then yeah we one had hot encoded the
positions
we took the game average of the previous
year this is 20
and our uh original data set that we are
training on is of 21 so
by 20 i mean 2019 to 2020 that season
and so yeah we took the
game average difference from average
rank so like yeah we have a bunch of
ways to see how did a player perform in
a particular game we to train our model
now once we have this we took the home
and away data now that is something that
i mean i think almost all sports
analytics models take
so now we'll build a model now
i i have something to say that this
isn't a very good model
it can be a little useful yeah i'm
paraphrasing a famous code it's okay so
uh
it can be somewhat useful in
understanding how hierarchical models
should be built or what can be better
ways to build uh
models for predicting
football stuff but yeah i mean let's
just get to it
so i'm i'm using the development branch
ymc
because i want you to see that you know
how is it working and everything and a
few features are still missing but
we'll be releasing an alpha or a beta
version really soon
so yeah look out for that that's that's
going to have a back end of sr so we
took all our data we split it into train
and test
and
now
this is uh one of the few priors that we
took so if you're
like not familiar with uh
bayesian statistics like this new minus
one thing is
basically that uh
from from the paper
bayesian estimation supersedes t test so
they uh
they use
i mean in general we use student t
distributions when you know it's it's
like a particular version of a normal
distribution when you wanna
when you wanna have like
heavier tails or something so in those
cases uh i mean prior to something that
actually are very subjective and
there's no real way to say these are
good priors but yeah you try to
incorporate as much knowledge as you
have and if you don't then you shouldn't
be informing that because that will
definitely make your model worse but
yeah flat priors again worsen your
computation time so it's like basically
a very thin balance line
now uh
this is how you insert data in pmg
that is something that we already did i
think in the previous models
so yeah you gave all your data i mean
this is the only data that we'll
actually be using these clustered ramps
that i told you about the initial value
home
and average scores their teams and their
one hot encoded positions
now
uh so yeah this is where your
hierarchical stuff begins
so
this is say you know we want to measure
the opposition's defense strength
so
we take a particular distribution for
that and then we say okay the
now this will have different effects on
the forwards right and different effects
on the midfielders and different on the
goalkeepers
but the overall strength of the
opposition's defense will play a factor
in all of them so we're accounting for
the similarity and the differences
so yeah that similarly we do that with
home and away
and split that into you know these four
positions
okay
yeah this is this is the same thing as
we did with the opposition with that
particular team strength i mean if
you're
i mean this is something uh so a
significant portion of this model
is uh from a a model somebody had built
which is again in the references and i
was thinking that okay if opposition has
such an incredible part or whatever i
mean we don't know if it's incredible
but yeah it would play a
crucial role similarly the team's
strength itself is going to play a role
i mean yeah if you have like you know
people who are passing properly or
everything so yeah i mean the same
player in different teams would play
differently so yeah we took that
and now it's like we split the
opposition strength into defense and
attack and team
and yeah these are just those i mean
this is this this gets very big and that
is that is probably one of the things
that are not very good about this model
i mean there's a fair chance a lot of
these parameters are
you would say uh
i mean one of them is taking into
account
the effects that the other one is trying
to predict so
they're not really useful and it would
probably require more domain knowledge
and more testing the priors because most
of the dryers over here are like almost
similar to flat fryers because
i do not know enough to say that okay
you know this is the prior i should be
taking so yeah i took these very big
priors
and yeah finally we we evaluate one of
the first likelihood there'll be two
likelihoods the first one is
we take the defensive strength
uh
to account for the
difference from average
like as in the difference from the
average of the previous seven matches
like that is what we expect that you
know that is what the player should be
scoring maybe like in 2020
in seven matches this was their average
score so in 2021 it should be somewhere
near that so we think that okay maybe
the teams they played against were
better so or worse which caused the
difference
so we do that
and yeah then we add up all the other
teams uh like you know the uh that
the player otherwise uh the
position-wise effects
depending on the team that they were in
uh and we
evaluate a second likelihood
where so
i don't know if you've used stan or
one of the other probabilistic
programming languages i mean there are a
ton and many of them are like doing
great work but i think one of the things
they like about ymc is that it's like
sort of really easy to
you know
just put in things like i just mentioned
observed as this one thing and i
mean but that's probably something that
is easier in python and the cost we pay
is that the computation time is higher
so yeah it's a balance now this sampling
took 30 minutes so i just saved the
trace the trace is basically the data
we're getting from it i mean you know
all the samples that happen
so this is saved and i just loaded it
and yeah this assert
the result isn't in this presentation
but the r hat was not nice
it was like 1.4 or something
for some parameters
so
yeah not a very reliable model but what
we want to say is okay does it work at
all now okay we will just try to test it
on
uh our test data set so we had 44 000
samples in the
uh initial uh posterior that we were
evaluating so we have again 42 000
samples
now one of the things that i did here
that you might have noticed is i used
metropolis which is not a very reliable
way to sample
it's just that it was taking like really
really long samples and
uh
so yeah metropolis was somewhat faster
in this case but if you're using
something for
you know production or something that
you want to deploy and you want like
more reliable results wouldn't really
advise doing that
and yeah so this was basically the
number of players in like 15
among the actual
top 15 players in those weeks and the
ones we predicted and we had like seven
in common
so which is like all right we got some
of the players now
i mean i i don't think these statistics
matter a lot
uh what really matters are like the
trace plots that you generate from i
mean not just trace plots i mean you
know all the
ways that you can diagnose that whether
your model
is working really well or is it just you
know is this just a random stroke of
luck that you got some values right is
it reliable enough so like a few days
before uh this i was just finishing up
the model and i was like really
struggling with it i started really late
and uh
you know so i was talking to a few of
the folks at finding and i was like okay
you know i made these mistakes and uh i
have no idea what am i gonna do and so
they were like okay maybe people can
learn from your mistakes
and you know bad modeling choices
so
one of the few things was uh when you
try to generate trace plots for this
model you get about since there are like
25 or 28
random variables the whole plot is not
even viewable and so i just
didn't really put it here but yeah there
definitely
is no reasonable conversions okay five
minutes to go
yeah
okay yeah so yeah these players you
predicted
and i don't watch a lot of football but
i think it's like all right
so
these were the references okay i really
wish that you would read this notebook
it's like
uh uh
the link i've put is the updated version
i mean the docs currently in ymc are in
sort of three versions the stable one
with int 3 documentation and this is the
latest one now this has uh
uh this basically sums up like
multi-level modeling as a whole concept
as in
when you start with mixed models when
you're varying intercepts you vary
slopes and partial cooling and you know
with proper figures in everything and i
think it'll be really easy to follow so
i think you should check that out
and now i guess if somebody has
questions i'd be happy to deal with them
um i think there's a bunch of questions
in the
chat
are we predicting the full season or n
weeks ahead and similarly are you
measuring performance only after the
full season now i am not predicting the
full season so
uh i
i just use the 2019 to 2020 data as uh
for getting the seven week average of
the 2021 2020 to 2021 season i mean
so i'm just predicting like up to the
first half
like well out of say how many game weeks
are the 38 like probably the first 19
game weeks and one thing that i do is
that i eliminate
some of the players who have really low
points because they tend to skew the
entire distribution you know players who
have played for uh only a few minutes or
something like that
and
yeah i mean i only used minutes played
to eliminate some players
nothing after that
and how does it compare to these nodes
and the massive data model that is used
in the community
i have no idea i did not compare i did
not do any cross validation because i
did not find
similar models on this data set that
we're working so yeah
uh nuts yes not
in buying steam is nuts
cool uh thank you for your talk
great thank you